this is exciting you're from Delaware
you were just named Delaware's most
famous person I think that's really cool
that's a state that's an entire state
and you're at a bet most famous person
there and plus I was thinking about it
today that means you beat Joe Biden I
know I know I honestly don't know how I
did that he didn't even make it in the
top three is that true yes and I was
trolling him on Twitter because I was
like how did this happen
howhow do you were vice president yeah
but I am just really famous there for
many things I guess yeah
were you and who else did you be I'm
just curious who else's Wow Valerie
Bertinelli good yeah yeah George
Thorogood in the Delaware destroyers
that was the name of his band what Andy
[Applause]
all I know is should be pissed at you
yeah yeah it wasn't it was a vote
it was like an online vote I don't know
I don't I didn't ask for this I heard it
I heard dr. Heimlich of the Heimlich
maneuver yeah Henry Heimlich what's up I
beat you he saved millions of lives yes
you can for one yeah you're getting real
cocky about it first state number one it
is the first date that's right that's
right first state to ratify the the
Constitution yeah whatever we're number
one and everything whatever were you you
were are you you're famous for some
things that you did there when you were
first getting started out still living
in Delaware didn't you pull a few stunts
that the people still talk about to this
very day yeah they had the picture of me
when they announced my my number one
position was of me in a duck costume
mm-hmm
because my I'm famous for going into a
McDonald's in a very dangerous
neighborhood dressed as a chicken and I
had a bunch of little kids that were
also addressing chickens costumes
because we were doing the ugly duckling
at the community theater mm-hmm and this
isn't like a funny story but I just
asked the woman at the counter if I
could have a 20-piece human McNugget I
said we don't have that and I was like
well what do you have and she said
chicken and then I started screaming and
like squawking so this is this is what
this is what got you in this sort of The
Legend of Delaware I don't know but
probably okay people still talk about it
Joe Biden never did that yeah
he couldn't do that yeah he didn't
commit to it
you